Guten Tag, mein Name ist Dekram Özvalık. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Arzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen ein Aufnahmegespräch durchführen. Alles in Ordnung?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstanden oder Fragen haben, bitte lassen Sie mich es wissen.
Ich brauche ein paar persönliche Daten, dann können wir weiterfahren.
Aber Herr Doktor, ich habe schon meine Versicherungskarte gegeben.
Ja, ich weiß. Aber das ist sehr wichtig für uns, damit wir Sie nicht mit anderen Patienten verwechseln.
Es gibt so viele gleiche Namen, wie Sie wissen.
Ok, Herr Doktor, klar.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Florian Wilms.
Könnten Sie bitte langsam ein Nachname beschreiben.
F, L, O, R, I, A und N.
F mit V.
Mein Nachname beschreibt sich V, W, I, L, M wie Martha und S am Ende wie Samuel.
Alles klar, vielen Dank. Und wie alt sind Sie, Herr Wilms?
Herr Doktor, ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 2.02.1982
Wie viel wiegen Sie, Herr Wilms?
Ich wiege 94,5 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,87 Meter groß.
Herr Wilms, was für Sie ist uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Seit ungefähr einer halben Stunde habe ich plötzlich starke Brustschmerzen.
Hier, Herr Doktor.
Es fühlt sich an wie ein Messer.
Und es ist bis in den Hals.
Was habe ich denn?
Das kann ich jetzt nicht genau sagen.
Aber wir sollten noch ein paar Sprünge darüber machen.
Okay, aber es ist schon schlimm, Herr Doktor.
Sie haben schon gesagt, diese Schmerzen haben vor einer halben Stunde angefangen.
Ja, und seitdem habe ich schon.
Plötzlich oder langsam?
Plötzlich angefangen.
Eine halbe Stunde war ich im Büro, ganz in Ruhe, Herr Doktor.
Aber plötzlich ging es los.
In Ruhe.
Die Schmerzen bekommen.
Haben Sie jetzt Schmerzen?
Ja, aber besser.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala?
0 ist kein Schmerzen und 10 sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen.
Am Anfang vielleicht 8 von 10.
Im Moment ist es wie gesagt etwas besser.
Vielleicht 4 bis 5.
Aber ganz weg ist es eben nicht.
4 bis 5, alles gut.
Herr Wims, da jetzt ein Notfallverdacht besteht,
ich muss jetzt das Aufnahmegespräch unterbrechen.
Dann ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Auf jeden Fall ein Elektrocardiogramm und ein paar Brutuntersuchungen durchführen.
Dann können wir weiterführen.
Alles gut.
Ich habe keine andere Alternative, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe Schmerzen und Sie sind Arzt.
Ja, alles gut.
Wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt?
Können wir weiterführen?
Natürlich, Herr Doktor. Wie gesagt, habe ich keine andere Alternative.
Bitte machen Sie weiter.
Herr Wims, ich würde gerne fragen,
haben Sie vorher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Ja, ähnliche Beschwerden hatte ich schon letztes Jahr.
Vor zwei bis drei Jahren.
Vor allem im Sommer und vor etwa zwei Monaten.
Im Sommer? Etwa vor drei Monaten?
Ja, vor zwei Monaten.
Damals haben Sie nur bei Belastungen aufgetreten.
Zum Beispiel beim Treppensteigen.
Sie haben ungefähr 30 Monate gedauert.
Ungefähr?
Ungefähr 30 Minuten gedauert.
Halbe Stunde gedauert.
Ich würde gerne fragen,
waren alle Attacke beim Ruhe?
Ja, bei Belastungen.
Aber heute war ich im Büro und im Ruhe.
Heute im Ruhe.
Vorher waren alle Attacke bei Belastungen.
In der Belastung, aber heute anders.
Ja, im Ruhe. Alles klar.
Verstehe.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
Sie haben vorher im Sommer ähnliche Beschwerden
zwei oder drei Mal erlebt.
Wie lange dauert das?
Sie haben schon gesagt,
ca. 30 Minuten.
Ja.
Alles gut.
Gibt es noch etwas Ähnliches?
Gleichzeitige Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel Brustschmerz, Atemnot.
Brustschmerz habe ich schon.
Ich hatte auch Atemnot.
Vor allem am Anfang war es auch stark.
Aber jetzt habe ich keine Atemnot, Herr Doktor.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Auch übel habe ich.
Übelkeit habe ich.
Mir war auch etwas übel.
Aber ich musste nicht erbrechen, Herr Doktor.
Wie bitte?
Keine ohne Erbrechen.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Kahlschweiß oder Schwindel?
Was gibt es?
Ich kann davon erzählen.
Ich war plötzlich ganz verschwitzt, Herr Doktor.
Aber der Schweiß war kalt.
Kalt? Ja.
Haben Sie Angst?
Ja, natürlich, Herr Doktor.
Mir wurde schwarz vor Augen.
Aber ich bin nicht unmächtig geworden.
Ja. Schmerz vor Augen. Seit wann?
Seit halbjahr.
Ja, am Anfang. Besonders am Anfang dieser Attacke.
Alles klar.
Und ja.
Diese Beschwerden.
Aber jetzt fühle ich mich besser.
Gott sei Dank.
Alles klar.
Wie ist Ihr Apathie?
Ich habe in der Zeit keinen Hunger mehr, Herr Doktor.
Ja.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit abgenommen?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Ich habe in den letzten drei Jahren so drei Kilo zugenommen.
Genau. Drei Kilo.
Haben Sie Geschwörle in den Beinen bemerkt?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Farbeveränderung oder Geschwörle in den Beinen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Hab ich bemerkt, ja.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Sie haben nach Angst vor Tod gefragt.
Ich kann sagen, ehrlich gesagt,
ich habe nachts Angst einfach zu sterben.
Besonders nachts.
Deswegen kann ich nicht gut schlafen, Herr Doktor.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Besonders Todangst.
Todangst heute ist Tag, aber nein, seit Langem.
Seit Langem.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Ja, seit einem Jahr vielleicht.
Ich meine über die Schlafstörungen.
Wegen dieser Todangst kann ich nicht gut schlafen, Herr Doktor.
Ich verstehe. Sie haben Schlafstörungen wegen Todangst.
Ich bin nicht so alt, aber das ist interessant.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Wie ich 100 Jahre alt bin.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorge.
Haben Sie noch Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt, Herr Doktor.
Das ist sehr wichtig beim Wasserlassen. Gibt es noch andere?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Fühlen Sie sich febrikt aktuell?
Aktuell nicht.
Okay. Herr Wims, haben Sie noch weitere chronische Erkrankungen?
Was heißt chronisch, Herr Doktor?
Dauhaftige. Bluthochdruck oder Krankheit oder Bronchitis zum Beispiel.
Ja, kann sein. Ich habe Bronchitis, Herr Doktor.
Seit wann haben Sie Bronchitis?
Seit 5 Jahren denke ich. Ich muss immer husten wegen dieser Krankheit.
Dagegen nehmen Sie ein Medikament oder?
Ich nehme einen Ausflüfflöser. Aber der Name ist anders.
Ich denke, Acetylsystem. Um diesen Ausfluss zu lösen.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Ich kenne nicht die Dosierung, Herr Doktor. Aber morgens nehme ich dieses Medikament.
Alles gut.
Kein Problem. Und noch etwas? Gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich habe keine andere Medikament.
Aber vor einem Jahr habe ich meinen Hausarzt besucht.
Er hat mir gesagt, dass ich auf meinen Cholesterinspiegel achten soll.
Was machen Sie für mich, Herr Doktor?
Ihr Hausarzt würde Ihnen Aufmerksamkeit machen.
Ihr Cholesterinwert ist ein bisschen hoch.
In der letzten Zeit würde ich Ihre Cholesterinwert überprüfen.
Herr Doktor, ich habe seitdem darauf nicht geachtet.
Wie Sie wissen, ist Ihr Cholesterinwert Blutfettwert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das aktuell ist.
Ich würde gerne ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Nach der Blutuntersuchung kann ich etwas sagen.
Danke, Herr Doktor.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wichtig für Sie ist.
Aber mit 25 Jahren hatte ich eine Virusinfektion.
Zytomegalie heißt das.
Meine Lymphknoten waren damals ziemlich geschwollen.
Ich wurde damals mit Hilfe von manchen Medikamenten behandelt.
Aber ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern.
Meinen Sie Zytomegalie Virus?
Natürlich kann ich nicht so ausreden.
Aber genau so.
Vorher, seit wann?
Ja, wie gesagt, mit 25 Jahren.
25 Jahre.
Leider habe ich keine Notiert.
Haben Sie aktuell eine Lymphknoten oder Geschwollen?
Nein.
Herr Wülps, was haben Sie als Medikament?
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ich nehme nur diese Medikamente, die ich besuche.
Haben Sie schon gesagt, dass es eine Medikament ist?
Ja, das ist eine Medikament.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass es eine Medikament ist.
Keine andere Medikament.
Nur SSS.
Ganz gut.
Herr Wülps, haben Sie vorständig geimpft?
Ja, gegen Corona auch.
Herr Wülps, haben Sie etwas gegen Allergie?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergie.
Herr Wülps, rauchen Sie?
Leider rauche ich seit Jahren.
Wie oft und seit wann?
Herr Doktor, wegen Stress rauche ich täglich 20 Zigaretten seit 3 Jahren.
Aber früher war es weniger.
10 Zigaretten habe ich früher geraucht.
Früher halbe Schachtel, aber in den letzten 3 Jahren eine Schachtel.
Seitdem ich 18 Jahre alt war, rauche ich.
Sollen Sie mal versuchen mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören?
Ich habe viel versucht damit aufzuhören, aber ich konnte es nicht schaffen.
Das ist sehr schwer.
Aber wir können Ihnen eine professionelle Unterstützung bieten.
Ok, lieber.
Nach dem Gespräch können wir darüber sprechen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich trinke auch Alkohol.
Aber nicht zu viel.
1-2 Flaschen Bier und 2-3 Gläser Wein pro Woche.
Pro Woche?
Besonders am Wochenende.
Diese Frage nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine ganz, ganz, ganz rote Frage.
Haben Sie schon mal Drogen ausprobiert?
Nein, warum fragen Sie danach Herr Doktor?
Wie gesagt, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Weil Drogen manchmal Nebenwirkungen mit bestimmten Medikamenten haben können.
Nein Herr Doktor, ich habe...
Deswegen sollten wir immer diese Frage stellen.
Herr Doktor, ich habe keine solche Abhängigkeit.
Aber ich bin abhängig vom Kaffee Herr Doktor.
Ich will zu viel Kaffee, ich denke.
Ich will nicht das vier Tassen.
Ich auch. Aber Kaffee ist ein legaler Drogen, kein Drogen.
Herr Wilms, haben Sie noch in Ihrer Familie eine chronische Erkrankung?
Bei Vater oder Mutter?
Ja Herr Doktor, mein Vater ist leider 50 Jahre an Herzschlag verstorben.
Er hatte auch Bluthochdruck und Grüne Sta.
Ihren Vater, Grüne Sta...
Das tut mir auch nicht.
Ja, ich habe Angst, wie mein Vater Herzschlag zu haben Herr Doktor.
Werde ich davon sterben?
Bitte denken Sie so nicht.
Ja, Herzprobleme manchmal natürlich ärztlich sein können.
Aber das ist nicht Regel.
Wir sollen einfach Unterzucht durchführen.
Herr Doktor, ist Grüne Sta...
Bitte?
Entschuldigung, ja Grüne Sta.
Ja, ist Grüne Sta ärgerlich?
Was ist das? Was ist Grüne Sta?
Grüne Sta bedeutet, ist ein innerer Augendruck.
Das ist auch ein sehr wichtiges Thema.
Es muss immer behandelt werden.
Ja, ok Herr Doktor.
Meine Mutter leidet an Rheuma.
Leidet an Rheuma.
Ja, ich verstehe. Rheuma, Tische, Arthritis, aber lebt noch.
Ja, und zweitang lebt sie noch.
Und meine Schwester, ist es auch wichtig für Sie, ob sie welche Krankheiten haben?
Ja, haben sie noch eine Schwester, wenn ich das verstanden habe.
Sie leidet.
Ich habe eine Schwester und sie ist Adipose, Herr Doktor.
Adipose.
Übergewicht, ja.
Und hat Warizen.
Warizen, ja.
Krampvater und?
Entschuldigung, Krampvater, ja.
Kennen Sie, wie viel wiegt Ihre Schwester?
Ich weiß nicht, aber sie ist ziemlich übergewicht.
Ja, ziemlich übergewicht.
Ich verstehe.
Herr Wims, sind Sie verheiratet?
Herr Doktor.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Meine Tochter.
Nein, ich sage nicht leider, aber ich bin sehr genervt Herr Doktor.
Ich habe Probleme mit meiner Tochter, dass sie sich in der Pubertät befindet.
Meine Tochter und meine Frau streiten immer.
Ja, ich verstehe, das kann sein, aber die Pubertät ist eine weitere Erwicklung.
Natürlich können Sie ähnliche Probleme erleben.
Wie alt ist Ihre Tochter?
Sie ist elf Jahre alt.
Ja, am Anfang.
Sie ist sehr jung.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Ich habe noch eine elf Jahre alte Tochter.
Natürlich Pubertät ist ein bisschen ein Problem, aber wir sollen ein bisschen Zeit geben.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Herr Doktor, ich bin Speditionskaufmann.
Speditionskaufmann?
Ja.
Ich schreibe Speditionskaufmann.
Wissen Sie, was ich mache oder was Speditionskaufmann bedeutet?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich kenne den Speditionskaufmann.
Sollen Sie mir erklären?
Ja, ich plane und organisiere die Gütertransporte.
Gütertransporte? Danke für die Information.
Gerne, Herr Doktor.
Herr Wilms, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Ich würde gerne wissen, was ich habe und was Sie für mich machen sollen oder müssen.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, dass Sie Angst haben.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf, wie Sie sagen, Akut-Coronare-Syndrom, wie Herzanfall.
Aber das ist jetzt nur eine Vermutung.
Um diese Diagnose zu bestätigen, können wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich werde als erstes einen Körperentwurf durchführen und Blut auf das Labor abnehmen.
Dann wieder ein EKG-Elektrokardiogramm durchführen und dann können wir wieder darbe springen.
Okay, Herr Doktor.
Ich werde sehen.
Tschüss.
Danke.
Herr Doktor, wenn wir hier aufstehen, sagen wir Tschüss oder auf Wiedersehen.
Wie gehen wir dann auf die Klappe?
Da ist nichts zu sagen. Sie werden hier auf mich und ich komme gleich.
Wir geben keine Zeit. Du hast gestern 30 Minuten gesagt.
Du hast die Zeit nicht. Du hast zuerst die Zeit.
Dann gehst du schon.
Da ist nichts zu sagen.
Ich glaube, Sie haben es sehr gut gemacht.
Es gab eine Akut-Coronare-Syndrom-Krise, da waren noch viele Fragen.
Danke für Ihre Arbeit.
Ich werde jetzt etwas sagen. Ich werde es dir sagen.
Die Kilo der Frau und der Frau ist nicht wichtig.
Okay, dann müssen wir sie nicht fragen. Sie können nicht verstehen, dass wir eine Kopie von dort haben.
Nein, sie sind nicht wichtig. Sie sagen es, weil sie viel reden.
Sie müssen nichts über die Patienten fragen. Wie viel Kilo war das? Was war das?
Die Nischweste, die Post oder die Anleitung sind für Sie nicht wichtig.
Die Nischweste ist eine Frage, die nicht nötig ist.
Die meisten Patienten können die Zeit nicht beantworten.
Sie können die Zeit nicht beantworten, wenn sie nicht nötig sind.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Ich habe die Zeit nicht beantworten, obwohl sie nicht nötig sind.
Muss man die Zeit nicht beantworten?
Nein. Aber die Frage ist normalerweise, um einen generalen Begriff zu schaffen.
Aber die Frage ist, ob man die Zeit nicht beantworten kann.
Wir sagen nicht, dass es eine Akutkulinarsthema gibt.
Alle Arten.
Das kann man sagen, aber das ist ein Fehler.
Aber um das zu verstehen, muss man sich das nicht beantworten.
Das ist eine Akutkulinarsthema.
Ihr Herzblut hat eine Verletzung.
Ich habe mit Ketin-Holga darüber gesprochen.
Wir haben uns so viel darüber überdenkt, aber ich habe es nicht erinnern können.
Ich habe es nicht erinnern können.
Du wirst sagen, dass du Angst hast.
Aber du bist im Krankenhaus und du wirst alle notwendigen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Das ist ein Problem.
Du hast es schon gesagt, dass du eine Notfallsituation hast.
Du kannst es nur befreien.
Du wirst alle notwendigen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und sofort fangen wir die Therapie an.
Das ist besser.
Du wirst sagen, dass du dich auf alle Dinge anders denkst.
Du hast mir das gesagt, jetzt sagst du das.
Das ist nicht sinnvoll.
Das ist richtig.
Die Frage der Notfallkontaktion war sehr schön.
Du hast die Arten und die ähnlichen Symptome zusammen gefragt.
Wenn du klassische Fragen hast, wird sie aus diesem Lied ausgeführt.
Ich werde die Frage von Bruce Emerson, Lufnod, Engegefül, Herzrazen stellen.
Welchen von diesen hat er mir gesagt?
Bruce Emerson hat es gesagt, Herzrazen hat es gesagt.
Laden Sie unter Lufnod, Engegefül.
So werde ich es fragen.
Der hat mir bereits ein paar Szenen gesagt.
Dann werde ich es so sagen.
Ich bin aufgefallen, dass ich Schwindel, Müdigkeit oder Angst habe.
Ich werde es so sagen.
Warum? Weil es von Herzrazen, Schwindel, Herzrazen gesagt wurde.
Ich habe die beiden Fragen über die Symptomatik und den Aktivismus gefragt.
Bevor ich die Frage anschaue, werde ich mir sagen, welchen von diesen ich gesagt habe.
Ich werde es mir so sagen.
Okay?
Ja.
Okay.
Ich werde es dir so sagen.
Du hast es gesagt, dass du Schwindel ist, aber meine Schwindel ist das Herz.
In der Schwindel fühlt sich der Patient nicht.
Aber es gibt eine Schwindel, die Schwindel...
Wegen der Schwindelaktivismus?
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist das Bild, das wir sehen, aber weil das Patient immer schlecht ist,
schauen wir uns nicht an.
Ich erinnere mich an einige Schwindel, die schweiß und kalt sind.
Die Schwindel ist so verblendet.
Du schaust nicht an die Schwindel?
Die Schwindel schaust du immer an die Schwindel.
Du schaust sie immer an die Schwindel.
Du machst das gut.
Im Moment ist es so, dass du nicht so gut in der Klinik bist.
Wenn du eine gute Geschichte erzählst, musst du die Antwort auswählen.
Man ist demoralisiert, wenn man das nicht sagt.
Man kann sich das nicht beinhalten.
Wenn man das nicht sagt, ist man zuerst sehr beinhalten und man ist nicht entspannt.
Dann wird es anders.
Dann werden wir auf jeden Fall aufpassen.
Ja, es ist wichtig, die Schwindel zu entspannen.
Die Schwindel zu entspannen ist wichtig, um den Körper und den Körper zu entspannen.
Das war alles, was ich von meinem eigenen Übergang gelernt habe.
Okay.
Aber ich möchte mich an die Fragen an Florian erinnern.
Das sind sehr detailliert.
Und es gibt auch sehr genannte Angelegenheiten.
Diese können wir auf alles verwenden.
Diese drei Seiten sind sehr effektiv.
Schaust du die Fragen um die Schwindel?
Ja.
Oder Reaktionen?
Ja, die Reaktionen, die Florian in den Alpharons gemacht hat,
und die Beweidungen, die ich für sie gemacht habe.
Ja, die werden auch für andere Themen genutzt.
Natürlich.
Die Technologie wird geändert.
Das ist das gleiche.
Ich habe bereits eine Reaktion gemacht.
Ich habe die Informationen schon gegeben.
Einige Arten machen das.
Viele Arten können das sagen.
Alle haben das gleiche.
Viele Arten fragen, ob das ein Erdblut ist.
Das ist nicht unbedingt.
Es gibt viele verschiedene.
Wir werden heute die Ursae, ihre Bechwerden finden.
Sie haben das gleiche.
Ich habe das nicht verändert.
Ich kann es schneller sagen.
Ich kann eine schnellerere Reaktion machen.
Wenn man alle miteinander denkt, kann man nicht mehr in die Arbeit gehen.
Danke.
Bitte.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich weiß es.
Labor anruf machen?
Ja.
Chetin, möchtest du es machen?
Ich kann es auch.
Das kann sein.
Ich habe die Dialo nicht gemerkt.
Ich bin nicht der Beste.
Ich mache es heute.
Okay, ich mache es heute.
Kling kling.
Hallo, ich bin Özgüval.
Bitte schön.
Ich bin Frau Müller aus dem Labor.
Entschuldigung.
Frau Bergheim,
das Kaliumwert liegt 2,58 Millimitern.
Können Sie bitte diese Werte Ihren Oberarzt weiterleiten?
Ja gerne.
Das mache ich.
Okay, schönen Tag.
Tschüss.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag, Herr Özgüval.
Herzlich willkommen. Woher kommen Sie?
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Seit wann sind Sie in Deutschland?
In ca. 3 Jahren bin ich in Deutschland.
Wann haben Sie Ihr Medizinstudium abgeschlossen?
Ich habe mein Medizinstudium im Jahr 2003 absolviert.
Wow, Sie hatten viel Erfahrung gemacht, oder?
Ich hoffe.
Nicht ich hoffe, ja natürlich.
Sind Sie Fachärztin?
Ja.
Welche Fachrichtung?
Ich bin Urologin.
Seit wann sind Sie Urologin?
Ca. 13 Jahre.
Ja, ich bin Urologin.
Seit 2013 bin ich Facharzt bei der Urologie geworden.
Und dann habe ich 2. Jahr gearbeitet bei der Urologieabteilung.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sie haben auch als Allgemeinerärzt gearbeitet?
Ja, natürlich.
Vor der Weiterbildung?
Wie lange haben Sie als Allgemeinerärzt gearbeitet?
2 Jahre habe ich als Allgemeinerärzt gearbeitet.
Und dann habe ich ca. 2 Jahre Kinderchurkei gearbeitet.
Und dann habe ich in der Urologie-Fachrichtung begonnen.
Okay. Was ist Ihr Ziel in Deutschland?
Ich möchte als Arzt in meiner Branche arbeiten können.
Was bedeutet Branche?
Meine Branche ist Urologie.
Wird Branche benutzt in Deutschland?
Ja, meine Branche ist nicht deutsch, kann es nicht in der Französisch sein.
Ich meine Branche nicht in der Französisch.
Aber nicht Branche.
Branche ist falsch.
Deutsche sagen Branche.
Okay. Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Florian Wilms, 42 Jahre alt.
Am Ende haben Sie auch mit Florian Wilms kennengelernt?
Kostas, danke. Heute war er sehr gut.
Ganz höflich.
Ich glaube, dass Sie sehr nett sind.
Deswegen ist er höflich.
Okay, bitte schon weiter.
Bevor ich die Branche in Deutschland verabschiede,
möchte ich Ihnen etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Ich habe gerade einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Es geht um Frau Bergmann, Kalin Werte.
Sie ist 2,58 Millimiter pro Liter.
Sie ist deutlich niedriger.
Was bedeutet das?
Hypokalämie.
Das heißt, das spricht Hypokalämie.
Die normale Werte ist ca. 3,5 und 5,5.
Was soll ich tun?
Muss ich die Werte der Hypokalämie erklären?
Nein, wenn der Prüfer die Prüfer fragt, kannst du erklären.
Aber wenn du keine Fragen bekommst, solltest du nicht erklären.
Wissen Sie, welche Ursachen gibt es für die Hypokalämie?
Es gibt viele Ursachen.
Vergangssystemprobleme,
Diuretik, Medikamente,
Ernährungsprobleme,
und Neuropathie.
Die Erkrankung von Chrono-Gas-Viren ist eine Ursache.
Herr, ich habe es vergessen, aber ich kann es nicht erinnern.
Vergangssystemprobleme,
Diuretik,
Medikamente,
Ernährungsprobleme,
Neuropathie,
Morbus Crohn oder Uterative Colitis kann auch Ursachen sein,
wegen sehr häufiger Diure.
Ich habe nur, ja ich vermute, ich weiß es nicht genau, aber ich vermute.
Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei der Hypokalämie?
Ich erwarte bei der Hypokalämie Pratikardien.
Ich erwarte bei der Pratikardien lange, gute Zyklus.
Ich habe keine weiteren Erfahrungen, keine weitererkenntnis.
Am wichtigsten ist die Herz-Hit-Mess-Störungen, besonders die Kamma-Filme.
Kamma-Filme, ja.
Wie wird Kamma-Filme behandelt?
Was machen wir bei Kamma-Filme?
Kamma-Filme, ich denke, Amiodarone oder Kardioversion.
Ich weiß es nicht genau, Medikament, aber Defibrillator machen wir sofort.
Kardioversion, nicht aber Kamma-Filme, Kamma-Tachycardi, Defibrillator, ja.
Ja, aber Kamma-Filme, nicht Kamma.
Wir sagen Kamma-Filme.
Welche EKG-Feränderungen gibt es bei Hypokalämie?
Ich denke, da ist die Bacchupilatachycardi.
Wie soll ich das erzählen?
Banchupilatachycardi ist typisch.
Also, es ist nicht nur Kamma-Filme, es kann auch andere Sachen machen.
Ich weiß nur nur, dass es das Kühlschrank ausbricht.
Also so, St. Zengkung, St. Stereke Zengkung, dann Abname D.A.T. und Spritze D.U.
Ich habe auch ein paar Dinge.
Sind diese Fragen?
Das kann man fragen.
Es gibt zwei Lagen Noten, die ihr drei-viermal aufschreiben könnt.
Das ist das, was ihr zuerst mit den Doktoren im Teil 3 macht.
Deswegen ist es wichtig.
Kann ich das erzählen?
Oder lasst mich das nicht.
Hyponatrimi, Hypokalemi...
Ihr werdet nur 5-6 Sachen sehen.
Okay?
Zwei Lagen Noten.
Ich habe noch nie die anderen Lagen Noten, die ich in den Doktoren habe, gesehen.
Ich versuche, die noch einmal zu Ende machen.
Du kannst es so machen.
Du kannst jeden Tag eine Lagen Noten aufschreiben.
Ich kann es heute machen.
Du kannst eine Lagen Noten aufschreiben.
Oder du kannst sie in der Reihe der Lagen Noten aufschreiben.
Etwa, wenn du heute Hypokalemi gemacht hast, dann kannst du morgen Hyperkalemi machen.
Du kannst heute Hyperkalemi aufschreiben.
Ich werde dich hier fragen. Du solltest versuchen, es zu beantworten.
Wenn du es nicht beantworten kannst, werde ich es dir sagen.
Du wirst es unbedingt lernen.
Okay, ich werde es mir sagen.
So, dass man es sich aus dem Augenblick erkennt,
ist das erste Kontakt mit dem Teil 3.
Du beginnst mit dem Teil 3.
Sie fragen sich auch darüber.
Dann können sie sich an die Frage beantworten, wenn sie nicht beantworten können.
Ihr müsst es nicht alle wissen.
Ihr habt ein paar Sachen über die Hypotrabe und den Symptom gesagt.
Das reicht auch.
Aber sag es sicher.
Hypokalemi, das ist ein sehr langes Thema.
Wenn du es lernst, wirst du nicht so weit.
Du bist nicht so weit wie ich.
Deswegen lern und beantworten.
Das ist etwas, das du nicht machen kannst.
Okay, was haben Sie noch?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich habe Florian Bild.
Er ist ein 42-jähriger Patient.
Er ist 1982 geboren.
Er wiegt 94,5 Kilo.
Er ist 1,87 Meter groß.
Er stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seiner Brustschmerzen vor.
Laut Angaben der Patienten sind die Schmerzen zunächst stehend und brennend,
aber aktuell drückend und dünn.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in den linken Arm und im Hals.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt am Anfang bei 8 von 10.
Jetzt liegt es aber bei 4 oder 5 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Der Patient gibt an, dass er ähnliche Beschwerden seit letztem Jahr im Sommer vor 2 oder 3 Mal erlebt.
Der Schmerz ist besonders bei Treppensteigen.
Er dauert ca. 30 Minuten.
Begleitet sind Anginepekturis, Neuse, Dyspia...
Was bedeutet Anginepekturis?
Brustschmerzen.
Aber Sie haben schon Brustschmerzen erwähnt?
Ja, ok.
Begleitet sind Neuse, Unerwährchen, Dyspia, Kalzweiß und Fatigue.
Vegetative anamnestisch ergaben sich in Appetanz seit heute Morgen.
Gewichtszunahme von 3 kg in den letzten 3 Jahren.
Schlafstörungen wegen der Todangst.
Als Vorerkrankungen leitet er eine chronische Hüste seit 5 Jahren.
Ihrem Hausarzt sagte ihm, dass er Hypocholestin nehme.
Aber weitere Infos gibt es nicht.
Medikamentos nimmt Acetylsthin in unklare Dosierung.
In unklare Dosierung ist die Allergie nicht bekannt.
Zudem braucht er seit dem 18. Lebensjahr in den letzten 3 Jahren eine Schachtel Protak.
Aber vorher halbe Schachtel Protak.
Der Alkoholkonsum wurde 2-3 Flaschen Bier pro Woche.
Der Drogenkonsum wurde verleint.
In der Familienanamnese berichtet er,
der Vater ist an einem Herzanfall verstorben.
Die Mutter leidet an rheumatischen Arthritis.
Die Schwester leidet an Adipositas und Baritzen.
Herr Wilms ist ein Speditionkaufmann.
Er ist 11 Jahre alt und gesund.
Aufgrund der anamnestischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf Akutkornarsyndrom.
Was bedeutet Akutkornarsyndrom, Herr Doktor?
Akutkornarsyndrom ist eine Notfallsituation.
Eine Veränderung im Blutgefäß.
Das ist ein Stabilangine Pectoris.
Herr Doktor, das ist sehr gut.
Ich habe gestern das gearbeitet, aber es war etwas so.
Nein, das hast du sehr gut gesagt.
Es ist nichts, das du anstecken musst.
Aber du hast es weitergegeben und es erklärt.
Du hast es nicht verstanden.
Du hast gesagt, dass du den Blutgefäß im Herz hast.
Das ist eine ursprüngliche Situation.
Du hast gesagt, dass du nichts falsch machst.
Das Wichtigste ist, nicht zu hören und etwas zu sagen.
Du hast auch gesagt, dass du es nicht gut kennst.
Es ist kein Problem, dass es eine ursprüngliche Situation ist.
Okay, Herr Doktor.
Was bedeutet Akutkornarsyndrom?
Ja, plötzlich aufgetretenes Brustschmerzen.
Und dann Schmerzkarakter, stechend, dumpf, in der Lasterzeit, drückend.
Und es gibt eine positive familiale Anamnese.
Der Vater verstorben an Herzanfall.
Der Patient raucht seit dem 18. Lebensjahr täglich ca. eine Schachtel Zigaretten.
Er konsumiert auch Alkohol.
Und der Lebensstil ist sehr wichtig.
Er hat viele Risikofaktoren, meinen Sie?
Er hat viele Risikofaktoren.
Okay. Wer hat einen Feriendiagnosen in Betracht?
Die Feriendiagnose ist eine Lungenembolie.
Und das ist eine phagielle Reflexkrankheit in Betracht.
So eine weitere Abklärung? Was würden Sie durchführen?
Ich würde gerne als Erstes einen Körperentfluss durchführen.
Dann Blut für Labor abnehmen.
Blutbild.
Leber und Nierenwerte.
Herz, Enzyme, Troponin, T, S, K, Kraten, Kinase, M, B.
Genugparametal.
Und ja.
Ich würde gerne einen EKG durchführen.
Und einen Kardiologikkonsum.
Anfragen.
Ich gebe mir fast eine CT-Angiografie.
Oder Coroner-Angiografie.
Anfragen.
Okay. Wie können Sie den Patienten behandeln?
Als Erstes beim Notfall.
Auf jeden Fall würde ich diese Patienten intensiv aufnehmen.
Und der erste Maßnahme ist Morphin.
Am Anfang 3 mg.
IV-Gespräche.
Und Sauerstoffgabe.
Wenn die Sauerstoffsättigung unter 90%.
Und dann gegebenenfalls, wenn es benötigt ist, Nitroglycerin.
Und auf jeden Fall.
A, S, S, A, C, T, C, H, V.
300 mg IV-Intravenous.
Und Heparin.
5000 Unite oder Unit.
IV.
Wenn es nötig.
Nach dem Stand könnte es ein Klobidobl.
600 mg.
Zusätzlich würde ich empfehlen, bei Bedarf Antiematik.
Und so wie ein Sedative.
Ja, super. Sie haben sehr gut gemacht. Ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Ich hoffe, dass wir das im Test ansehen.
Wenn du das ein paar Mal wiederholst,
dann ist das nur ein Fall.
Du hast es schon ein paar Mal gemacht.
Ich habe viele Fragen nicht gefragt.
Normalerweise kann man auch in einer SL-Krise fragen.
Aber niemand hat mich gefragt.
Meine Frau sagte, mein Vater ist tot.
Ich habe gesagt, dass er nicht weh ist.
Warum habe ich die Frage, die er tot ist, vergessen.
Oder die acht, neun Fragen, die ich über den Schmerz habe,
ich habe fünf, sechs Fragen.
Eine meiner Schwestern hat mich nicht gefragt.
Ich habe sie nicht vergessen.
Aber sie können fragen.
Das ist kein Problem.
Ich habe dann gemerkt,
dass wir jetzt nur die Relevanten für Daniece handeln.
Deswegen habe ich mich nicht gefragt,
warum der Mann mir so auf die Hände hängen und so auf die Hände schauen.
Ob er mir nicht sagen würde,
dass seine Schwester auch Depressionen hat.
Ich habe nicht gewusst.
Sie haben mir die Nachteile nicht erklärt.
Ich wollte das sagen.
Sie können ihn bis zum Ende handeln.
Das ist etwas an unserer Nachteile.
Vielleicht konnte ich die Nachteile nicht finden.
Sie wollten mich sehen,
dass sie das nicht können.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Hörst du, was ich da gesehen habe?
Was?
Du hast die Flur geflogen.
Nein, ich habe die Nachteile nicht gesehen.
Die haben sich nicht verstanden.
Ja.
Es gibt viele Dinge,
die sich an die Kommission verändern.
Ich versuche, die Nachteile zu vermitteln,
damit ihr Lied verwendet wird.
Wenn sie etwas verhören,
fragen sie die anderen,
ob sie die Frage verstehen,
ob sie eine richtige Information bekommen.
Deswegen ist es wichtig,
die Nachteile zu vermitteln.
Es ist wichtig, uns selbst zu vermitteln.
Die Zeit dort,
die Nachteile zu vermitteln.
Ich hoffe, dass ich die schönen Menschen beherrschte.
Es wird schön sein.
Ich habe eine Liste,
die ich immer wieder vergesse.
Ich habe auch Laborkapel.
Wir haben heute die Hippokaleme gemacht.
Wir werden morgen die Hippokaleme wiederholen.
Dann die Hipponatrami.
Wir haben uns jeden Tag hierher gefragt.
Schau mal auf die Hippokaleme.
Ich dachte nicht, dass sie so auf den Anleitungen stehen.
Sie sehen, dass sie da stehen.
Okay.
Dann muss ich hier rein.
Danke.
Und dann wird es nicht so schwer sein.
Nein, wir werden es lernen.
Ich sage es, weil wir weit sind.
Ihr seid auch das selbe.
Wir stehen seit Jahren weit von diesen Sachen.
Wir haben uns nicht um die Sprache betrachtet.
Ist das ein Sprachverfahren?
Wer kommt?
Sprache ist nicht das Problem.
Man muss sich die Sprache ganz auf die Stimme schauen.
Man kann viele Dinge nicht wissen,
aber man kann es sich nicht wissen, wie man es erklärt hat.
Wenn man darüber sprechen kann,
ist das nicht das Problem.
Sprache ist die Stimme.
Aber es ist ein bisschen schwer,
wenn man darüber sprechen kann.
Deswegen können wir uns vorwärts vorbereiten,
wenn wir die Fragen stellen können.
So können wir sprechen.
Wir sprechen,
aber kann ich sprechen, wenn ich auf der Straße bin?
Ich versuche, mit den Eltern von Kindern oder den Eltern von Freunden
oder mit ihnen etwas zu sprechen.
Ich versuche, eine Art Weg zu finden.
Sprachen ist nicht einfach.
Aber das ist ein Bereich, in dem wir vorwärts vorbereiten können.
Ich habe eine kurze Antwort.
Ich bin wieder in die Anamnesie.
Sie haben wieder etwas gefragt.
Ich bin wieder in den Firecrankungen.
Sie haben gesagt, sie wollen nicht, dass ich in der Anamnesie weitergehe.
Sie haben gesagt, sie würden mir nicht die Anamnesie ausgeben.
Dann hat sie mich gehalten.
Sie haben gesagt, sie hätten mich nicht ausgeben lassen.
Sie haben mich angewiesen.
Sie haben gesagt, sie würden mir nicht die Anamnesie ausgeben.
Sie haben gesagt, sie hätten mir keine Technik ausgeben lassen.
Vielleicht hätte sie die Anamnesie nicht ausgeben lassen.
Sie haben es nicht verstanden.
Sie haben es verstanden, dass sie alles für uns versuchen,
um uns spontan nicht zu sprechen.
Sie haben es verstanden.
Ich kann noch etwas sagen.
Ich verweise meine Erfahrung so,
Ich hatte einen großen Fehler im Test. Ich konnte nicht im Moment bleiben.
Denn ich habe nicht gut gesprochen.
Die Worte, die aus dem Mund kommen, wurden mir als Frage zurückgezogen.
Oder die Sprache wurde unterbrochen.
Aber jetzt kommt der zweite Test.
Ich werde hier wieder in die nächste Runde gehen.
Ich werde alles machen, was mir anreicht.
und das ist ein Thema die ich mit behandeln werde.
Ich werde meinen Prüferlust werde.
Der Tile 3 antwortet, dass nur die Tiefkrankheit für diesen Tiefkampf der Tiefkrankheit
Ich denke, dass es wieder gibt und dass es helfen kann.
Wenn ihr noch Fragen habt und eine Reaktion wollt,
dann sprechen wir darüber.
Wir haben noch 10 Minuten.
Jetzt so, in den Fragen.
Akut Koronar Syndrome.
Es kommt mit Schmersen, mit Bruce Schmersen.
Das wichtigste ist, dass es mit Schmersen genau wo ist.
Wo genau haben Sie diese Schmersen?
Wie haben Sie diese Schmersen?
Hier muss man sich auf die Hälfte der Patientin beachten.
Momentan, momentan, schmersen.
Momentan haben Sie diese Schmersen.
Das kann man an der Anfang verstehen.
Heute Morgen haben Sie Schmersen, momentan Schmersen.
Heute Morgen haben Sie Schmersen.
Momentan haben Sie Schmersen.
Das kann man sagen.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass es mit Schmersen geht.
Ich denke, das ist sehr wichtig.
Denn, Stabil Angina, also instabil Angina,
einer der Grundeinheiten der Akut Koronar Syndrome,
wie er entsteht,
ob es mit Schmerzen oder Belastonklau entsteht.
Wenn es mit Belastonklau entsteht,
wenn es kurzweilig und selbstlos ist,
dann sagen wir es als normales Anginepektor.
Wir sagen nicht instabil, sondern stabil.
Und meistens werden die vorherigen Schmerzen
mit instabil Angina verwendet.
Deswegen ist diese Frage wichtig.
Schmerzen plus, Langsam aufgetreten,
die Kippdes eine Bechte auf die Ausluf,
die Schmerzen, zum Beispiel haben Sie sie an
Brüskorp, Ferles oder haben Sie eine Stressgesituation,
Erlebt,
die ein Problem sind.
Und dann haben Sie Schmerzen,
die nicht ausgehen und z.B. in den Hals,
in den Lincoln Arm?
Dann fragt man es.
Dann zeigt der Akut Koronar Syndrome,
dass es mit Schmerzen, mit Schmerzen,
mit Brüsten und mit Schmerzen ausgetragen ist.
Dann kann man auch sagen, dass es keine Schmerzen ist.
Ich möchte Sie nicht unberuhigen, aber Sie haben eine typische Symptome für Herzkrankheit.
Deswegen muss ich das Gespräch unterbrechen.
Ich möchte sofort eine EKG schreiben, etwas Blut abnehmen, um Ihre Herzfunktion zu beurteilen.
Das ist die Anxthabung.
Ich habe diese Antworten auch bekommen.
Dann komme ich zur Arie.
Es gibt nicht viel, was ich zu Arie sagen möchte.
Du kannst das hier sagen.
Ich finde es nicht sinnvoll, die Faktoren zu beantworten.
Ich möchte Sie nicht unberuhigen, aber Sie haben eine typische Symptome für Herzkrankheit.
Dann komme ich zur Agitativanamnese.
Ich habe hier die Anxthabung.
Dann komme ich zur Klassik.
Ich werde jetzt ein paar Reaktionen machen.
Die wichtigste Reaktion ist, hier unterbrechen zu machen.
Ich habe es vorhin bei Ekrem gesagt.
Ich habe Angst vor Herzinfarkt und sterben zu haben.
Er hat hier einen Herzinfarkt.
Ich habe hier die Anxthabung.
Ich habe hier die Daten.
Diese Fragen sind für uns sehr wichtig, um sie mit anderen Patienten, um sie nicht mit anderen Patienten mit gleichem Namen, gleichem Alter zu verwechseln.
Das ist das, was ich immer sage.
Das ist für uns wichtig, diese Fragen zu stellen.
Sie müssen nicht mit anderen, die gleiche Name und die gleiche Alter sind.
Diese Fragen sind für uns sehr wichtig, um sie nicht mit anderen Patienten mit gleichem Namen und gleichem Alter zu verwechseln.
Das ist das.
Ich habe dich sehr erwartet.
Was war das?
Deutsch Arzt.
Ich verstehe Ihren Wunsch.
Aber momentan sind alle Arzte mit anderen Patienten beschäftigt.
Deswegen sollen Sie ein paar Stunden warten.
Aber ich kann sofort um Ihre Beschwerden kümmern.
Können Sie anfangen?
Das ist das, was ich sage.
Ich kann auch ein paar Informationen geben.
Was haben Sie?
Das ist das, was ich sage.
Ist dieser Patient so?
Ist er so, dass er sich um die Äkologie bewegen möchte?
Ich mache solche Situationen so.
Wenn Sie eine Beschwerde haben,
können Sie die Arzte mit anderen Patienten mit gleichem Alter verwechseln.
Dann können Sie sie mit anderen Patienten mit gleichem Alter verwechseln.
Ich sage, dass ich den Patienten bevorteile.
Ich habe ihn bevorteilt.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob du es zu Beginn gesagt hast.
Wenn er es zu Beginn gesagt hat, sage ich es so.
Aber wenn ich in der Mitte meine Meinung ist,
und wenn ich meine Meinung ist,
dann sage ich es so.
Manchmal ist es so, dass der erste Patient
nicht mehr sagt, dass er seine Meinung ist.
Es gibt 20 Patienten.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass man die Patienten nicht sagt.
Aber wenn man eine Beschwerde hat,
dann muss er die Ärzte beweisen.
Wenn er sie nicht beweisen möchte,
dann muss er die Ärzte benutzen.
Dann können wir es so sagen.
Diese Fragen sind für uns sehr wichtig,
damit Sie nicht mit anderen Patienten
mit gleichem Namen und gleichem Alter verwechseln.
Oder einfach nicht verwechseln.
Damit Sie nicht mit anderen Patienten verwechseln.
Okay.
Was noch?
In diesem Fall haben wir eine extra Not.
Es gibt nur eine Brief.
Gästkorn.
Oder Arpacik.
Er fragt seine Frau.
Ja.
Das ist ganz ehrlich.
Es gibt nur eine
H-Folikas.
Aber auch eine Lid.
Das reicht.
Das ist in Ihren Schreiben?
Ja.